you know a lot of people I gotta ask you
talking about the things you did say
about Marvel movies seeing the reaction
it got do you still stand by those
comments how do you feel now well look
what what the point is in terms of this
film Netflix theaters but I'm talking
about really are films that are made
when let's say a family wants to go to
amusement park that's a good thing you
know and at the amusement park there's
these cinematic expressions their new
art form it's something different from
films that are shown
normally in theaters that's all for them
my concern is losing the screens to
massive theme park films which I say
again their own new art form cinemas do
cinema now is changing we have so many
venues there's so many ways to make
films so enjoyable fine go and it's an
event and it's great to go to an event
like an amusement park but don't crowd
out Greta Gerwig and don't crowd crowd
out Paul Thomas Anderson and Noah
Baumbach and those people just don't
in terms of theatres you want to be a
part of this frame
would you like to be a part of this
history yes I would
whatever you need me to do I'm available
legends working together and longtime
friends was making this movie a bit
emotional or reflective for you at all I
would say yes I mean we weren't we never
articulated it but we knew Gennaro and I
Bob De Niro over the years last film we
made together was casino was 1995 and so
we really felt that over the years he
wanted to make one more picture at least
one more but it took us a while to find
the right story the right character I
should say and he came up with this book
that Charles Brandt's book
I heard you paint houses and he was so
taken by the character and when he
described it to me I grabbed the book
right away read it and I said I think we
could do this and it took a while it
took a while yeah got here yeah he shut
down Hollywood Boulevard built a whole
new Street for this one it's fantastic
we got drones a lot of awards buzz how
would it feel for the movie to get
recognized Oh it'd be wonderful for it
to be recognized but you know the thing
I always say you know I'm making films
like 48 49 years you got to make the
movies okay that you got to make the
film that's in it people appreciate it
that's great that's that's your reward
in a way you know everybody's talking
about this D aging technology was it a
little weird when you first saw like
younger Bob how did it feel it was it
was actually was rather exciting when we
saw the test and we realized wow this
could work I mean we works it's still
experimental at the time and while we
were doing the tests I mean each day the
technology got better so by the time we
shot the film was better by the time
we're doing the post it got better last
questions for you look you're you've
done this one you're doing Roosevelt
next what biopics do you still want to
do any that are still on your bucket
list and anybody you still want to work
with well that's a there's so many good
people now my god
but the next film we're doing is killers
of the flower moon so that is about the
Oklahoma Osage Indian nation in the
1920s they were the richest people in
the world from oil and then you know
some of the various goings-on I'm still
hoping you'll make that Sinatra movie
one day one day I hope what give him the
rights to the estate guide also Justin
Timberlake apparently so excited for
this movie he tweeted about it now he's
just coming to the premiere you fans of
this yes yeah yeah but I didn't realize
he was coming here tonight
Wow this is terrific
[Music]